so first of all
despite the cute thing that my kids said
I absolutely have yelled at my kids before
I talked on here before about how
respectful parenting wasn't always my method of parenting
and I have found my way into it and have gotten better with it over time
to the point now that me yelling is such a rare occurrence
that they don't even remember that I've done it
so how do you teach your kids emotional regulation
honestly you teach yourself emotional regulation first
and how do you go about that well
you look at what triggers you the most
and you ask why it triggers you the most
and then you do a great deal of therapy and healing
because there's always a why
now beyond that
because I know that probably sounds super
um difficult to start doing that sort of journey um
modeling emotional regulation
is the best way to teach your kids how to emotionally regulate
so when I get super overwhelmed
which we all do
I'm neurodivergent
I'm a stay at home mom
my kids are with me 24 7
we're going to get overwhelmed
I model things like taking a little break
doing some deep breaths
just standing in my body and being like
before reacting
and when you model those behaviors
those are what you're teaching your kids to do when you get overwhelmed
which is why I get very angry at my husband
who has less good emotional regulation skills
and throws giant man tantrum sometimes
but if yelling is something you wanna stop doing
it's okay that it can still happen every now and then
as long as you apologize to your kids
you have a conversation about why it's not like
the appropriate response to something
and you commit to do better
or try to do better in the future
and then back it up
it's okay for parents to be human
but we also have to be compassionate
I also highly recommend the book The Whole Brain Child
it taught me a lot about child development
and their even ability to have emotional regulation
and what kind of ages those things come into play
and the conversations you're gonna have about appropriate emotional responses
is gonna be different for the age of your children
but we have had ongoing and repetitive conversations about how tantrums
and outburst and yelling is the body's way of getting rid of all of the yucky
big feelings that you're feeling
and trying to throw them out into the universe so you can get rid of them
but it really just gives them to other people and expands them
instead of gets them away
you cannot give your anger to someone else and expect it to get smaller
that's the conversation I have with my kids
and you'll notice when you yell at your kids
you're not getting rid of your frustration and angry
you can almost watch it shut down the communication with your kid
and watch the
your kid become more angry or more sad
which is just big feelings turned inward
everyone gets overwhelmed
everyone gets ragy
everyone gets a short fuse every now and then
but practicing
and trying to do better each time you get in a situation where you feel that way
is the best way to do it
and the best way to get help in doing that is to search your own demons
I hope this helps